Let's see.
We're hearing from so many different people
here.
Why don't we go to Skylar from New York, Skylar
from New York.
You're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Awesome.
So I was wondering, obviously, for the better
part of a year we've been talking about, let's
just get the ball back, let's just have a
win and then we can push them.
How do we make the next four years productive
in that we're not just comparing everything
Biden does to what Trump did, but to actually
push them back and pressure him and educate
people to vote in more of their best interests?
Well, the first step, as we have to compare
Biden to his campaign promises, and you're
absolutely right, that if we simply say this
is how it compares to Trump, everything will
essentially be better.
Maybe we'll stumble across something where
we say, wow, Biden somehow is even worse than
Trump on this one issue.
I think those issues will be few and far between,
if any.
But I think the first step is we as progressive
media have to remind the audience not just
about what Trump would have done, but what
did Biden promise.
That's the start.
And if we forget that, then we don't stand
a chance.
And then beyond that, obviously, with the
midterms and hopefully growing influence for
the Progressive Caucus in the House of Representatives,
there will be continued pressure on Joe Biden.
But the most important thing is let's keep
let's hold Joe Biden accountable to his own
promises.
Yeah, because like I've already seen when
it comes to, like, people he's named in his
cabinet or the way that he's gone about just
like trying to work with Republicans, that
he's already getting a lot of pushback from
the left.
And then I'm also seeing my guys, whether
it actually be president for a week before
we start criticizing him.
Yeah.
And on working with Republicans, I think all
there is so far to criticize is what is there
to criticize.
Biden has said he wants unity and he looks
forward to making progress with his friends
across the aisle, like he likes to say there's
nothing wrong with him saying that it's naive
if he thinks he's going to do it because they're
not going to they will be obstructionist clowns.
But I think it's silly to criticize Biden
for saying it.
I think what Biden would be wrong to do is
to think that he'll be able to negotiate with
these people when they when he won't.
But so far, I don't I don't think there's
any criticism that would be levied just for
Biden saying he's going to try it.
I think it's great to say let's try to work
together and get things done as long as he
doesn't end up compromising on what he campaigned
on.
Yeah, I just don't know the most productive
way to raise the bar, because if you look
at the Obama administration, it's easy to
compare it to George W. Bush and say Obama
did a tremendous job.
But obviously, if that was the case, it wouldn't
have led to the election of Trump.
Well, that's why I think it's.
Remember, on paper, Biden's campaign platform
is well to the left of Obama's.
I would argue that Joe Biden's platform and
his campaign promises are the most progressive
of any president that has become president.
Now we have to hold him to them.
If we do if Biden does the stuff he promised,
then we're going to be moving the Overton
Window left.
If Biden comes back from his promises and
just operates as a centrist, then we're going
to be extraordinarily disappointed.
Absolutely.
Yeah, so I guess, you know, all we could do
at this point is wait and see and make our
voices heard in the most productive way possible.
Absolutely.
And make your voices heard through your local
representatives.
I mean, your members of the House and Senate
that represent where you live.
Yeah, well, thankfully, my representative
is and Kathleen Rice, so I had a lot of work
to do.
OK, yeah, that's an uphill battle.
All right.
All right, my friend, thank you so much.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up, because
we're going right back to the discord tubes
for more phone calls in
a moment.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.
Welcome back to
The David Pakman Show.
Let's get back
to hearing from you via discord at David Pakman
dotcom slash discord.